[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
mon coup de coeur il s'agit du film la
vie des autres de Florian heinekel
vandenersmark qui est sorti en 2007 il
s'agit d'un film allemand et qui parle
au final de l'Allemagne parce que ça
parle vraiment de cette époque de la
guerre froide ou l'Allemagne était
séparé en deux l'Allemagne de l'Est et
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest sachant que
l'Allemagne de l'Est était une dictature
à l'époque donc ce film en fait se passe
dans cet Allemagne de l'Est dans cette
dictature qui raconte l'histoire d'un
auteur de théâtre qui va être surveillé
par la Stasi la Stasi c'était le
ministère qui qui est en charge de
surveiller un peu ce qu'on prenait pour
des espions à l'époque ou qui ne
suivaient pas bien cette règle de
l'Allemagne de l'Est
[Musique]
et donc en fait le film au début on va
croire que ce film est sûr cet auteur de
théâtre mais en fait non il est sur le
personnage le policier qui surveille
donc qui est juste au dessus de son
appartement avec son casque et qui
surveille cette hauteur de théâtre qui
va se rendre compte en fait petit à
petit qui vit dans une dictature et
qu'il est au service du d'une dictature
et que ce qui fait cette espionnage sur
ce sur cet auteur de date n'est pas
normal je vous conseille vraiment ce
film parce qu'il est il est bouleversant
le jeu des acteurs et et incroyable
regardez-le en VO bien sûr un sous-titré
en français il a eu d'ailleurs l'Oscar
2007 meilleur film étranger voilà je
vous conseille la vie des autres de
Florian heinekel von denersmark
[Musique]